defiant and determined these protesters
are calling on the government to resign
despite rounds of tear gas and recent
violence they have occupied Baghdad's
Tahrir Square ignoring military orders
of an overnight curfew no to the curfew
we will remain here the curfew is one of
their filthy games and tales nearly 60%
of Iraq's 40 million people live on less
than $6 a day they're fed up with high
unemployment and what they call top
level corruption they say the country
needs new leadership there are so many
young men that have been killed so many
have lost their lives further south in
Karbala protesters say they were shot at
with live ammunition governor says those
claims are false well and then with
video circulating online that were
fabricated and tampered with which are
not from the province of Karbala I
reiterate this news is false and
baseless over the last month more than
200 people have been killed and
thousands injured in anti-government
protests this is the second wave of
nationwide protests that began in early
October many of the protesters are
students and they are back with renewed
anger this is a popular demand asking
for greater changes greater reforms in
the government and greater services it's
a huge challenge for prime minister Adel
Abdel Mahadi he's only been in power for
a year he's promised to reshuffle the
cabinet and introduce reforms but he has
refused to resign saying chaos would
follow the Illuma the prominent Shia
cleric moqtada al-sadr controls the
largest bloc in parliament and he's
called on the government to announce
early parliamentary elections the number
of people are writing here in Qatar
where continues to grow we're seeing a
lot of students the teachers and the
attorneys unions have told their members
to stay home and come here to show their
solidarity a curfew goes into effect at
midnight
Natasha Ghanim al jazeera Baghdad